in 1 hour in exactly 1 hour at 1:30
we're going to do something we've never
done
before Mahar Zay and Harris J in Ramadan
in Medina in front of the grave of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
they're freemix and
singing did you know that teaching a new
Muslim like me the entire Salah for the
next 50 years just cost £10 every time
they wake up for f door
you get the reward you could sponsor
salams for just 00 and help 10 new
Muslims learn how to pray Salah click
the button or the link and donate
[Music]
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends it's
Ramadan the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him said sallallahu alaihi wasallam
Allah is not in need of the one who
obtains from food and water if he's not
going to stay away from backbiting
slandering
ill speech foul language Ramadan is not
just about from abstaining from food
guys if this what you think Ramadan is
about you have not understood what
Ramadan is brothers and sisters we are
brothers in humanity sisters in humanity
one of the things that reever love about
us is what that we are brothers and
sisters Allah tell us in the Quran let
the Believers be soft towards one
another and harsh towards the enemies of
Islam why is it that when we differ with
someone yes that of course
I may sometimes be guilty of this but
why is it that when we're different with
someone we hate the person we become
hate hate hate and of course you can
hate for the sake of Allah because they
can come a point where for example
someone like Andrew Tate outright
sinning openly any attacking Muslims
this kind of man he has to be attacked
simple as that
however the videos I'm going to show you
that was sent to me and people might
think I'm just doing a video now and I'm
attacking no I'm not I know brother
Harris J I've spoken to him I don't know
brother Mah yes
alhamdulillah Harris J he's had his
mistakes he's a change man we're Sinners
we're all Sinners alhamdulillah yes and
he's got a beautiful Quran recation yes
I'll say literally i s with him and his
father may Allah bless him and I met his
father and I'm not doing this but I'm
say you guys know I don't have a loyalty
to anyone just cuz I know I don't work
like that anyone that knows me knows me
after been working brothers who I was
close with but because I believe them to
be wrong I've spoken against them after
I've G them M so and the same is
expected from me the videos we're going
to watch now inah is that I want to
watch the first one first because
firstly there's an accusation so this
brother done the video and I want to
react that first and then we're going to
go and see the that they' done and see
actually is the accusations does it fit
where it is and then in Ramadan while
we're fasting to keep our tongue we want
to break our fast with food right we
want to break it with food yes we don't
want to break it with the Flesh of our
brothers and sisters do we you don't
want to break your F by slandering
someone we don't want to do that okay so
brother says I'm going to get straight
this we're going to react to this video
of this brother he seemed like a person
of knowledge I guess I don't want I want
to say that a bit Loosely I don't any
disrespect because he's wearing the
thinging just cuz he wears the Garment
doesn't mean that we need to be very
careful these days um I don't know the
brother may Allah bless him preserve him
in he has a concern let's watch in and
by the way some of us can break our fast
with Sak yeah it's not just not
literally but you know what I mean by
that is not that you need to give I'm
saying brother and sisters you can help
teach 100 people to learn how to playay
Salah you can teach thousands the wo the
Salah Subhan Allah so go to the link in
guys we're doing a project and if we get
if we win inshallah brother sister if we
can raise 20,000 in the next three days
we're going to get an extra £4,000
please go to the link and help teach
someone how to pray Salah do and even
learn F let's go let's watch this video
in Mah Zayn and Harris J in Ramadan in
Medina in front of the grave of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
they're fixing and singing and some of
the girls they were dancing and they
were taking selfies and fangirling over
these celebrities imagine in front of
the Prophet you're fangirling over
another celebrity this is one of the
worst things I've ever had the
displeasure of seeing and by the way all
the Muslim influencers out there that
are promoting this song we know who you
are and you know what you are enabling
may Allah hold every single one of you
accountable first from first before we
go to the videos of the actual n Etc um
just so you guys can see and we're going
to see the full video in context
inshallah and we're going to see is
there free miix in now the brother said
something very deep he said this was one
of the worst things I've
seen with I mean I'll be honest with you
I firstly number one they're not in
front of the prophet's grave that's not
true I'm not saying the brother's line
misinformation they are not in front of
the Prophet grave if they were in front
of the prophet's grave doing this I
would be like you know what that's
that's Crossing Lines that's Crossing
Lines they were not in front of the
prophet's grave they were in front of
Medina the prophet's Masid now you might
come and say well what's different the
Masid calm down relax one second number
two he said this is the worst thing I've
seen no brother the worst thing I've
seen is shik the worst thing I've seen
in my life is people come to say Jesus
is the son of God Jesus Is God yes okay
that is the worst thing I've seen yes
okay and after sh the worst things I've
seen is people in Gaz been massacred yes
okay that's the worst thing I've seen
bro when you're using big words you're
making it seem as if it's it's it's it's
not good it's not nice because what
you're doing is you're ring people up
you're getting people agitated and then
that's why when you go to the comments
you can see people backbiting you said
we're in Ramadan you having to go at
them for what they're doing okay talk
about that in a minute but then again
you are enabling people to backbite them
you're in Ramadan bro you're you're
enabling people and you're making seem
as brother they might be wrong we're
going to come to that we'll talk about
that in a minute but for you to say like
this the worst thing and those who are
doing it may Allah hold you accountable
brother relax relax okay why do we have
to go to extremes they may be doing
something wrong we're going to come to
in we're going to watch the video now
but why go to the thing of may Allah
hold you accountable this the worst
thing I've seen in front of the Prophet
great which is not true put into context
okay because sometimes people exaggerate
things take it out of context and I'm
not saying like for some people they
would see as like that but let's calm
down and let's take it STP at time this
is the n this is vocals only I think
there was no music or something yeah
this is this is what the Nashid that's
going around
[Music]
so that was the nid yes without the
music now this is them asking people to
come before they added on the video so
let's look at brother Harris J and
brother M so this is what they've said
well guys we're here in Medina we got a
surprise the time is 12:30 right now in
1 hour in exactly 1 hour at 1:30 we're
going to do something we've never done
before yeah never ever done before we're
going to be here meet us at this frame
in front of the Prophet Sall Ali
wasallam M and we're going to do a video
together it doesn't matter where you're
from Indonesia Malaysia anywhere around
the world come and get involved in the
video If you guys if you guys have
family in Medina call them come in one
hour
be right here okay right here me at the
frame 1 hour one don't miss out we going
to sing together okay let's
do everyone that was um the video where
they're telling people if you can come
we're going to do whatever it is for
that matter that's fine come with your
families etc etc etc etc ET okay now
let's go to the actual video because the
first thing thing is that proves again
once again I'm not I'm not trying to
defend anybody here or this start Tak
anyone side I'm just saying we need to
look at facts number one it's not in
front of the Prophet grave that's very
clear you can see from the video that's
very clear they asking people to come
they did not say sisters come they
didn't say we want just women to come
they said if you your family members
come I think they're doing it they want
to add to the you know it's just showing
everyone's doing it yeah um again we can
talk about the music I believe musicam
they use Music uh they they deem it not
to be that's that's their opinion I
don't believe there is a valid opinion
forget that again I'm not going to go
into the nties I just believe music is
outright Haram people know my stance
here is the footage actually of what
happened in let's watch it and see for
ourself when people came it looks like
most of rels anyways
[Music]
sing it
okay now let's get into the whole matter
brothers and sisters Allah says in the
Quran in chapter
49 if I'm not mistaken that do not to
jump to assumptions in these some
negative assumptions is a sin now of
course there are there Brothers out
there like look I'll be honest with I'm
on that camp is what we going to call it
in the prophet s's Masid you know
sisters come in there sing and I'll be
honest with you it does look like it's
remixing because at the end of the day
what is the need for them to be there
for I person personally personally yeah
however however however um like I said
before I will I can come and say you
know that is free mixing no problem yeah
and we should obviously there are
brothers who are more stricter ex when
it comes to this kind of stuff you know
you know as if like men or women in any
way shape or form cannot this in this
instance I believe there's no need it is
free mixing yeah there's no need
there're singing sister are there Etc
that's what I do that's fine okay now
the point is this though and I'll be
honest with you the nid if it's no music
it's praising the prophet Etc it's fine
if there's no music it's something that
I will listen with my family no problem
yeah if there's no music involved yeah
now one thing we need to understand is
brother and sisters look I obviously
with this whole thing I believe it
should not be done if under the process
grave whatever but the thing is brothers
and sisters that when it comes to other
believers why do we have to have hatred
why does it have to be like we see
something we deem that we don't like and
I'll be honest there's a lot of
hypocrisy involved a lot of people just
don't like individuals and I'm not
saying that brother in the beginning I'm
not talking to him
some people just they don't like
somebody and because they don't like
someone they just use the dean as an
excuse oh it's it's not personal I hate
him for the sake of Allah no brother you
just don't like him you got personal
beef with him bro you just don't like
the guy whatever it is for that matter
or you don't like public figures for
that matter because obviously sometimes
unnecessary attention is given to them
and sisters and all that kind of stuff
look I'm just saying guys I hear those
who have a concern the brother who had a
concern I hear him but for him to go to
extreme of that's the worst thing I've
seen sorry about the wor sh yes shik is
the worst thing of on this Earth this
the biggest on the earth sh yeah this is
nothing I would prefer this happen all
day every day everywhere and no shik
happen all day every day this happening
every day but shik not happening yeah
and then to come and say you know may
Allah deal brother please relax calm
down okay we should give him a s it's
wrong no problem yes to say it is if
it's clear fre which I believe that you
can say that is Haram but to now have
hate towards Harris J and brother Mah
whatever brother calm down okay if they
follow an opinion that believe music is
permissible okay whatever and they might
be a bit more leaning on this issue we
are not but we can give a and say
Brothers It's better not to do kind of
stuff and if you're going to do it
everywhere don't do it at the prophet's
Masid you can give him a we can give him
a we can say my dear brother I don't
need to go and say you you are a Dalal
you are Antichrist you are this you're
Shan you're working with Shan oh he's
like this he works with eliminar oh this
that he's the enemy of Allah he's that
Wei please calm down bro relax man why
do you have to go to these extremes of
slaughtering people labeling giving
these mad names and this kind of stuff
balance people are out there people are
coming say oh the reason they're doing
that is because they follow M Omar what
ja like what ignorance now you're
blaming people that got nothing to do
with it oh they went there because they
follow seriously seemly that you're
backbiting brother you're fasting this
Ramadan and you're back by in the
comments yeah yeah this person yeah free
your tongue free your tongue inshah
Subhan Allah that's all I'm going to say
in brother and sisters with this
instance and may Allah subh guide me yes
I am a sinner just like Harris J and Mah
Zay yes they are our brothers in Islam
and we need to show them love yes if
they cross lines which I don't believe
they crossed a great line that it was
distasteful and I believe the freemix in
there is Haram yes and we give a yes but
other than that hostility backbiting SL
please abstain from it Ramadan be
careful guys be careful the last person
if you don't if you dislike them no
problem for the sake of Allah okay why
would you give your good deed to someone
you dis like for the sake of Allah bro
on why would you give good de to
somebody that you don't like please guys
Ramadan is may Allah bless and preserve
you guys let's do that and I'm going to
end on brother and sisters please
inshallah help us win the competition we
are trying to teach thousands of people
this year 50,000 plus people the next
coming years to teach them Salah even
qur if they done so when you given
you've done the de you get the word of
that and then teaching someone W and
then teach them how to and then even
teach them
Quran say this is we are teaching
thousands of people around the world be
a part of this Amazing Project go to the
link and donate
now I am a re and I was taught how to
pray Salah that means every single time
I pray the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from F to isan
if you want to support someone like me
in learning Salah then sponsor 10 people
for just £00 this Ramadan remember the
prophet peace be upon him said charity
does not decrease wealth click the
button and donate now oh